ah
we're live it's hot breath live everyone
we're live what's good
what's good
what's goody welcome to hot breath live
everyone
this is a weekly live stream where we
talk comedy topics and give you joke
feedback as well and we've got
we got some heaters to bring up today so
come on in everyone tavis
good to see you buddy 503 dude
is in the building as well he says aloha
y'all oh that's funny he must be from
south hawaii
because it's the sale
howdy y'all
micah in the building oh good to see you
micah
what's up mike
yeah so we gotta we have a very special
guest from the hot breath verse joining
us today as well
but we're going to let y'all
come in here
for a minute
as we
warm up here for this lovely tuesday
together how are you doing yoshi
i am doing good brother i um
things are moving i'm having a good week
um
i've got something big happen at the end
of the month that i'm super excited
about and so just like and i got a show
this week and so just you know
um you know i'm doing i'm doing i'm
feeling myself i'm feeling myself more
than usual
[Laughter]
oh god oh god
yeah man
i'm i'm feeling
i'm feeling that you're feeling yourself
i feel good about that
yeah yeah and i i will say i'm feeling
i basically ate this entire thing of
granola today so i'm feeling
sugar spike right now so hopefully
halfway through
we don't um
no
this is homemade granola though
by the way but yeah i basically was like
i'll just bring this into my office
and then i was like oh i guess i'll just
that's where it ends is
but it's homemade
i started announcing all the ingredients
it's real
yeah
but yeah cereal it's there's something
about cereal that just
i'll bring up that's why i go to therapy
i need help with cereal
hilarious
micah said does it have caramel in it
it has brown sugar
uh i did not use any like natural sugars
for this i used real sugars so
i know
um
is there like an alcohol
quote before brown before something
hilarious yeah liquor before beer
liquor before beer you're in the clear
beer before liquor you've never been
sicker
yes but isn't there like something about
brown liquor versus clear liquor
oh i don't see color um so i don't know
oh we got joan in the building
govio
but you do see sugar canes
i do see a lot of sugar canes yeah yeah
ryan shrilla says hola guys hola ryan i
posted on the facebook group i'm looking
for a i'm looking for a a spanish tutor
i need to brush up on my spanish
um so i can sell out dodger stadium like
fluffy did
um
oh and 503 dudes said i'm a redneck
hawaiian i love it
i work dodger stadium that's just light
work
but welcome to hot breath live everyone
this is so exciting to see everyone in
here
and i'm so excited
to bring on our special guest from the
hot breath here in a few minutes as well
but first things first
first things first what's the first
thing joel what's the first
the first thing we doing
is we've hit a milestone here
in the high breath
a milestone
uh milestone
stone oh and michelle said joel buyers
the sugar boy comedy tour
hilarious
you lose a foot and you lose a foot
i was no cap journaling today and i
journaled
i was journaling and i um
and i brought up an idea of doing a
one-man show
[Laughter]
no cap but i was journaling today
today but i i
should do a one-man show about
it's a meditation hour
[Laughter]
not to flex on y'all
but if we
if we are going to flex a little bit oh
and bumbletown said i love comedy well
we love you
oh snap and ryan shrilla
just hit us with a super chat my man
hit him with that hit him with the share
horn sharing love
much preach there ryan and he asked the
question with a super chat which is
always a great way to get your questions
answered here as well
so where can i have either of you on my
show mila's on me and i'd love to
interview the interviewers
well this is the first we're hearing of
it
skrilla let's get it
just say something you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah let us know let us know
are you expecting this five dollars back
is is he like and when you do bring a
five spot would you
[Laughter]
and that's two five spots yeah yeah yeah
so he just flipped he just doubled up on
a sweet lick there
yeah ryan we'd love to be on your show
for sure long john the comedian in the
building as well said hello everyone
bumbleton yes bumbletown we are doing
joke feedback but first we have a few
topics
to discuss and the first
ladies and gentlemen it's a big deal
it's a big moment for the hot breath
verse
thanks to you
we have just hit
20 000 subscribers
20 000 subscribers on the youtube
channel i mean come on
20 racks baby racks on racks or racks
20 000 subscribers on the youtube
channel so everyone that has shared the
channel thank you so much everyone that
tunes into this
every single week where we do this live
stream and on wednesdays i do a live q a
and a live joke writing contest
i mean thank you to everyone who has
shown support
you sharing this is a big part of why
people are finding it so keep doing it
we love you so much
20 20 racks bruh
i mean racks yeah i mean that's that's
that's that's big time you mean that's
that's you know i mean that's
that's that's cancel numbers you know i
mean
we might get canceled for getting 20
000. i don't hate it
i don't hate it i don't hate it
[Laughter]
i don't hate it i don't hate it i'm
gonna zoom you in a little bit oh there
we go we'll zoom you in a little bit you
got a lot of head space up there look at
you
you don't need all that headspace there
we go
so 20 000 subscribers we just wanted to
thank you all so much
uh bumbleton said congratulations ryan
gave the applause
oh this is love
gary henry said congrats
thank you all so much seriously man and
it's so early
in what we're building here at hot
breath together might i add
so we got here together and the goal is
still 50 000 this year so
we're gonna get there we're gonna we're
approaching the half
way mark of the year and i'm excited to
uh review what we've done so far and
then build upon that so thank you all so
much
we love you we love you all
and speaking of love the first topic
of the day
it is oh that's so funny every scene i
change is i'm gonna have to adjust your
camera never mind i just won't adjust
your camera
oh no i'll just oh never mind i'll just
bring it up like that there we go oh
that's perfect
yeah
um anyway anyway the first thing up is
the dave
uh chappelle situation
um
and i don't uh and kind of you know a
lot of people have been given their hot
takes on it and whatnot and that's cool
and dandy and whatnot but i think from
working comedians perspective
uh i think is a light that we can share
on it we're not tmz but we are comedians
out here in these streets
you know that could possibly maybe
be a victim to this maybe you know my my
squeaky clean youth pastor comedy can be
very divisive sometimes so hey
it can happen but what was your like
what was your reaction to this now will
smith coming on stage and then now
chappelle getting tackled at the
hollywood bowl you know which you know
you and i perform at regularly so it's
alarming yeah
we understand the stage we understand
how intimidating it is so yeah i feel
bad for for dave he hadn't been there
for a while so you know yeah like it was
just sea legs underneath him i think it
was a plant i think i think it wasn't
going well and he he and he like gave
the signal he gave the signal
for uh dude to come in and get him
yeah he did he did the logan paul
special so he can knock him out real
quick yeah
honestly though i feel like we're making
too big of a deal
about it
and the only reason i say that is
it's dave chappelle who is arguably the
biggest comedian
in the world right now
i'm not surprised that somebody attacked
dave chappelle
like
if you're going to attack the comedian
he is the one to attack
like will smith situation
was more
personal right that was just someone who
got upset in the moment at that
at the oscars it was just like i'm going
to do something about this
someone attacking a comedian on stage i
mean
like
we've heard of many other comedians have
been attacked on stage before in the
last like year year and a half two years
it's already happened
i think because it's dave chappelle and
now it's like in the zeitgeist and
he's pressing charges all these other
things it feels like it's
like it's happening all the time and the
reality is
it's not happening all the time
it's just is it
like i don't i don't know joe you've
been doing comedy for
11 years yeah how many times has someone
come up to the stage
based on how many times you've been on
stage i can't even
recall like a show i've been to where
anyone has been attacked on stage like
any comic on any of the shows
yeah i've been doing comedy seven years
never happened
like
and i get we it's not like we're
performing in front of 20 000 people on
a regular consistent basis anyway so i i
i know we're not at those stage numbers
but i feel like it's just been overblown
as if though there's like this huge
attack on comedy here's the thing
people are just upset like the world is
just going through some things right now
and really what i think what you're
seeing is just a reaction to people just
being unhappy
i don't think there's this huge attack
on comedy i just don't see it yeah in a
regular everyday comedian yeah i will
say it did happen uh recently like in
atlanta where somebody smacked a
comedian but they smacked the comedian
that was on the side and they were upset
that
there was a backyard party happening and
the neighborhood didn't know about it
like so there's like circumstantial
stuff that happens every once in a while
but
there's no problem where regular people
are just
running up on comedians i think it's the
same thing with like cancel culture or
people saying comedians can't get away
with anything anymore
most comedy shows people are going there
to laugh
yeah most people aren't going there to
get offended but it's when people get
offended that gets blown
out of proportion but i think that's
another kind of trending topic that's
not like it's not as rampant as people
are saying yeah it's and you're
absolutely right it's not as rampant now
i i don't want to dismiss the fact that
no one should be attacking people and
it's not okay just to
attack people
on stage that's that's not okay and no
one should ever
do it on a regular consistent basis
but as a working comedian
it's
i think you have to be very honest with
yourself it's like what do you do are
you really saying stuff by which people
are
all of a sudden should attack you and i
don't think there's really that much
that is to be said where people are
attacking you it's just not happening
the way that people i i feel like it's a
little overblown in the sense that it
feels like it's happening everywhere and
the reality is it is not happening
everywhere i'm gonna we're in atlanta
georgia
there's not a whole bunch of people
getting attacked on stage for doing
comedy just straight up
has run up on this topic we're getting
tighter with our topics y'all yeah yeah
so the next one
i'm like look at y'all each week it gets
better
yeah so uh the next one we have here
comedy specials uh we're not gonna do a
deep dive analysis but yoshi and i you
know we're friends we text so we we we
naturally talk about comedy specials so
i think it's a good idea even just to
kind of
give some flowers or shout outs to
people who did release some comedy
specials that we were able to check out
um
so i know
the the big one here in the hot breath
the verse all right we're not doing 10
minutes i love how i bragged about the
timer and now i'm
it's a work of progress everyone it's a
work of progress
but um
the the big one
the verse mr steve rogers stephen
rodgers a member of the hot breath the
verse og of the hop breath verse uh he's
been on the show
twice now and i'm going to have him back
on next week um
talking about him trying to you know
record the album get it produced and all
of this sharing that process so we're
going to have him back next week
but uh his special
filmed at the national
com
i always get the wording wrong national
comedy arts center
yes yeah so legendary location and um he
killed it so shout out to steve on that
one
yeah i really like steve special i like
steve as a person already yeah and so to
see
just his personality on stage
like you could just tell his jokes are
super duper tight like that's what i
like about his his structure and the way
that he writes and i think my favorite
part is i've seen him work this special
at right you know some of the stuff i've
heard a while back and so you know when
we were
very big into the zoom mics and doing a
lot of those feedback mics it was
working out those those bits and just
getting them nice and tight i really
liked it you saw a lot of personality
from them and just a lot of like
really good storytelling um within that
special i think that's my favorite part
about the special is like it was a good
mix of stories and then a good mix of
just like it's very quippy quick kind of
one-liners all the way through i really
enjoyed it it was a solid solid special
and i got it yeah it was very solid and
very funny and i think i was pleasantly
surprised and uh michelle said his
special so good and jones said his
special's so good i was pleasantly
surprised
about um
how loose he was he's very
written he's very structured
but he took it and i was pleasantly
surprised he looked like he had fun with
the moments and really kept those
moments in the special as well like i
was pleasantly surprised i knew it was
going to be knockout funny but just how
much fun he was having knowing how
structured he is it still came off very
loose
yeah yeah i think that's the part for me
that was my favorite part of the special
it's the part that didn't feel like the
jokes it was sort of the inorganic
moments there were organic moments in
this special of just like him
i i think there was a part where he kind
of
like had just a little quip and then he
forgot what he was saying i was like oh
yeah i'm enjoying this yeah but like
into it but like that was like the thing
it's like that's the human aspect of the
special it's like
sure it's gonna be
a little wacky because he's a little
wacky but i just like how organic he is
with it it actually reminded me um i
don't know if you remember the uh
your delia travis special a couple years
ago did they deal with comedy central
uh either with comedy central or he
filmed it at relapse theater oh no i've
seen that
it's really good he's very very funny
he's comedian out of atlanta georgia
he's in new york now he might be in l.a
now but he's very funny oh i remember
your daughter back in the disney out
here yeah oh yeah in the middle of his
special he just used the bathroom
like in the middle like while he's
recording just goes to the bathroom
and it is literally the funniest thing
and it's it's recording and he just goes
and then he comes back and it's just the
funniest like just organic moment that
you see he was just like he's just
having a good time doing a special and
he's got to pee
and
like i just enjoy those organic moments
for sure
yeah for sure
and uh ryan said christina p had one
come out on mother's day i haven't seen
hers yet but i did see she dropped that
uh joe list his special was good
did you see his oh my gosh there's a
humongous sign behind him that says joe
list and like his opening joke is like
the sign was a mistake
uh and he made a joke about how it cost
25 grand and all this but yeah it is
huge but you know joe is
absolutely hilarious um yeah
christie and i saw the uh chris the
stefano special on netflix
dude that thing was a ball it was just
fun it felt very club atmospherish
it felt like he popped and drank a
little bit and still killed
like which i enjoy but it felt like i
was at a party with a friend and he's
just like racking jokes off so i really
really enjoyed that
that's what's up yeah a lot of good ones
oh jacob said always enjoy when you two
get together on these thank you so much
jacob
yeah we enjoy when you all enjoy it
oh and i watched the earthquake special
once again
bruh
i'm gonna add a minute
i'm adding a minute
you know what i'm adding two minutes if
we're talking about earthquake special
let's go and add time to the timer
because
did i tell you uh
rodney rodney perry called me after
seeing one of our clips and was like i
bet you sold more of his specials than
he has how much we've been talking about
it
so funny dude
what it was i just like i just
and i watched the ronnie chang special
as well oh yeah yeah rodney and i talked
about that one too i watched that with
my wife yeah yeah
yeah i mean what's that special i i
enjoy that special too but i think you
know what it is is that that earthquake
special man
is a reset it literally does something
to you're like
it's so
packed in
with just
laughter
and jokes and it like
just the the rev up of just like it's
almost like you're going to a shooting
range and you're don't stop and just
like dude
every comedian i see i go have you seen
earthquake special like every comic i
see
i don't
i don't want to flex too hard because
chris isn't here but you know this
weekend i was interviewing lavelle
crawford
and
it's i saw i also watched
an old lavelle crawford special
and i forgot
how
incredibly funny do that mean well i
think i talked about the first time we
talked about earthquake special
that i was like i haven't seen someone
kill this hard since lavell crawford
and then
it it and he told me because i told him
he broke down an earthquake special he's
like we all got to break down and he
especially has on netflix he's like
because earthquake did for 30 minutes i
did that for an hour like he was like
him and earthquake have known each other
for decades you know so but he was like
earthquake's been doing that he's like
but you know i've been doing that is
what he was saying so we got to break
down his special when we dropped that
episode i watched so many i watched so
many specials in the last time i also
watched the
uh
miss pat special
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was very miss pat like
and it was so rich with stories it was
so good every time
i'm just like i can't believe you had
that life
it just doesn't seem real
it doesn't seem real at all and to find
the humor in it is just so inspiring and
why so many people are gravitating
towards her you know
yeah she's like yeah just
it's
it's refreshing to see her story or
anything associated with that kind of
story being told on tv i agree
yeah i agree
have you seen our tv show yet
i have not seen this show yeah i haven't
either it's on bet plus and i haven't
like subscribed to it um i don't have it
either they don't give it to black
people for free so that's come on
reparations if anything that should be
reparations they should
look at
them what reparations should be they're
like no mo mofo you should be buying it
for black people i think that's what
reparations would be
yeah
so this juneteenth i want every white
person to buy a black person
b-e-t-plus
[Laughter]
that's our 40 acres right there
the uh the next topic of discussion
we're gonna bring in our uh our very
special hot breath guest are you
drinking mountain dew
no what how are you 12
what
did you eat at mountain dew just on a
tuesday evening
when are you going to sleep
tomorrow
i've grown with kids drinking a mountain
dew just just nonchalantly that's
hilarious
i at least put it in a coffee mug you
know to hide it
that's the best place to hide it i don't
have any coffee mugs
i want to hook you up with a hot breath
mug
i actually i should have i don't have
any hot breath stuff around [__] oh i
used to have the shirt i know i need i
need to i need to plug the merch if you
guys are watching on youtube it's
underneath the video
um we got shirts and
hoodies and mugs and stickers and all
sorts of good stuff for the hot breath
of ours but what we also have the views
the viewers are dropping as we bring up
merch we went from 20 to 13. um right
there
we still got 20 000 subscribers that's
right baby that's right
yeah yay
so we're gonna bring in a hot breath
favorite here for those of you who have
been listening the podcast the past
several weeks we've been doing a comedy
author series
we've literally interviewed
the top comedy authors
in the game all of them we literally
interviewed all of them and this cat
we're bringing in is actually
responsible for that he actually reached
out to me
like oh we should interview all these
authors and do a series he helped book
it he helped do the interviews some of
the interviews he did himself like he
just did the interviews
so um i'm so excited to bring them on
here but ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the show
it's bo johnson everyone
oh
[Applause]
any dab there's your one
there's your one free dab for the year
i appreciate that both i gotta say that
the viewers probably dropped off so they
can go buy yoshi bet plus
that's a good point though i like that
that's a very good but the uh miss patch
show
fantastic
the miss pass
oh god it is so good and it's like it's
just it's all taken from her stand up
put into a show absolutely beautiful um
brace for impact when you see it because
it's
it's her stand up come to life basically
yeah i've heard nothing but good things
about it and beau was drinking a double
like espresso shot what's happening
triple shot
cafe minecraft from starbucks
you know i gotta say every time i hear
the word mountain dew all i think of is
the is the kid from talladega nights
you know when he's like going at the
ground he's like i'm all jacked up on
mountain dew
every time i hear mountain dew i think
of that kid
well thank you for joining us bo from
your isis bunker um we haven't seen you
on the show in a while so it's it's good
to know that you have joined the
brotherhood since the last time we spoke
guantanamo boat
guantanamo bow is what we'll call them
hey that's the name of my new my first
special what's haunted
for all the bombing that happens okay
we're we're on a roll now
uh because because i'll just be
torturing the people sitting there
oh hey the viewers have been yeah you
know it
i will say it has been a while you know
life got crazy uh in the last part of
the year and uh but everything's back to
normal and
we're here to rock and roll like i'm
ready to go yeah well
welcome back
welcome
back to the show man i'm excited for
what you got going on so yeah let's
break it down thank you yoshi thank you
captain ovation
captain ovation is that me why and why
why am i captain ovation
in maryland
joel byers with the standing oh
what
and like was this a pandering standing
ovation to where he's like hey y'all we
all stand up for this photo like that's
probably no he said i'm i forgot what
you said you said like i'm done or
whatever everybody stood up but i went
standing ovation it was it was like the
greatest like thing
to see
probably ever and it was it was truly
amazing seeing me do comedy live was the
greatest thing you've ever seen is that
what you're saying well i always say
doing that part seeing you get that
standing ovation that might have been
the greatest part but
i can't keep blowing up your ego for you
i know this is called hot breath
but we're not using hot breath to blow
up the ego blowing hot air right blowing
hot air at hot breath but yeah i
appreciate that yeah it was a great show
everyone did great that was such a great
job
for sure
yeah it was a lot of fun
oh and michelle called you uh bo dabbing
johnson so that sounds like an only
fan's account there i don't know well
but um i can't i look i am not the
dabber
joel byers dabber everybody that saw the
picture i actually took the picture
posted it on
on the uh hot breath facebook page that
the dab has been planted
in columbia maryland
[Laughter]
so that is officially part now part of
the hot breath of verse and uh
but now every time we go to a new city
there's going to be a dab a picture
posted and that's now official that's
part of the uh intake of the hot brother
birds amen amen
so
yeah the topic of discussion today
is our comedy authors series we've
interviewed gosh is it eight authors i
think so is jerry corley
there was a couple i went and actually
there was one particular win i did that
i interviewed that person
you had forgotten great
it was john um
vorehouse
four house yeah we had john vorehouse
greg dean judy carter
scott dickers
speaker greg dean i just looked in the
in a green room and he's still talking
he's passionate
he's a passionate person i want i do
want to get like him and uh jerry corley
together i want to do like
like a like a head-to-head like comedy
debate i just want to get them back
together and see what happened as as
interesting as that interview was
the thing that people don't know is we
turn the cameras off and that's probably
the part that they should have seen
is joel and ike like texting each other
like how do we get him to stop get out
of here
he's just very good questions just like
talking yeah
he enjoys comedy that's what happens
when you only die he does
he does but yeah so yeah
yeah
it was interesting it was really good it
was good
dickers stephen rosenfield steve north
elaine fetterman carter
judy carter had been the most
interesting one because you know
jerry seinfeld has the uh comedians
getting coffee and cars and we had
comedy advice going to the dentist yeah
um yeah so
anybody that did not actually see that
somehow we got to get that posted of
we judy carter took us down the
la freeway
giving comedy advice on people's jokes
yeah
yeah she gave a lot of joke feedback i
feel like we could bring people back
just to do joke feedback because like
her episode answered some questions but
also it was a lot of like people posting
jokes and her giving feedback which was
super valuable
definitely that's she laughed at one of
mine just saying
she liked yours
actually i want to say she did say she
wanted to come back standing jovation
you know i mean
this is all literally and fun i i've
been doing comedy too long to know that
she is fickle and if you get too
comfortable
she's gonna pull the rug out and i've
got a few big shows this week that i do
not want to risk
me in the middle of bombing and
remembering oh remember on hot breath
live when you were standing jolvation
so
moody
i don't want to blow up your ego because
after this show i know you have to you
have to go see caramel and um
i don't want her getting mad at you and
i don't should be like
uh you've been talking to bo again amen
preach preach
so what we want to do here honestly is
like
there's so much information to unpack in
these episodes and i i honestly think
it's
yeah i mean i i think it's a book within
itself i don't hate that idea either i
don't
hate that idea
i mean so the interesting part is and if
anybody has not actually gone and
listened to all of it
there's
so much advice in each of them and then
there's moments where
if you're taking notes you'll start to
see where two or three of them
start to say the exact same thing okay
like one of the big commonalities is if
your attitude and your emotion is not
there you're not gonna get the laugh if
your joke is supposed to be happy
but you look like help me i'm being held
against my will
prepare for the bomb
oh yeah anywhere you know
and that that was the big big
commonality is attitude and emotion even
if you don't want to be there you got to
put on because if you're not
if you don't put it in there
you're done so
you're you have to your joke has to have
an emotion but your delivery also has to
express that same emotion right it has
to express it you know um it has to be
there jerry actually at one point said
you know when when he was riding with
george carlin
carlin said just
raise your eyebrows
like you'd be surprised on how far that
goes you know and there's like so much
sold in the face
um like
so many people said this is where you
make the money you know that's a big
that's it
that's a big vince mcmahon and a
wrestling thing too it's like this sells
the money
is that why you're hiding your face with
that beard you don't like money you're
like uh i got lazy
and uh
yeah
no it looks it looks good man no it
looks good i'm just giving you a hard
time
so yeah that that's a big that's a big
one for sure yeah making sure that
there's emotion around your joke in the
writing but also in the delivery yeah
and so like when you're writing this you
actually have to start thinking okay
what is the emotion because that's
actually one of um jerry's things is the
emotion his you know the teaser um and
the e and t's are the first e is emotion
and if it's not there
you know then what's the point
yeah you can smell the joke all day long
but
and which will actually kind of help
with your eventually
your character persona which we can
discuss later is but if that emotion is
not there
you know because i mean go we actually
discussed this with i forget which
comedian it was but if you look at lewis
black
if he just stood there and did a rant
and just didn't you know
if he did a rant in the style of
um
steven wright
yeah if he did if he if
if he went up there and did those rants
like stephen wright
nobody's going to show up
but people show up and and louis black
admits it you show up because of the
emotion and the character that i that i
do
and it took him a long time to find that
character but his emotion is what really
sells that joke of that explosive
annoyance with everything around him
yeah yeah and it's funny you mentioned
uh the persona because i had people
in the hop retivers like send in
recordings of their big takeaways and a
few people mentioned the persona being
their biggest takeaway is being able to
like match like what they're saying with
how they appear to the audience
essentially you know right
right you know that and like with the
persona piece
and developing your persona developing
your character
that's where things get interesting
because
like jerry and scott said the exact same
thing
like if you want to find out who person
you are go talk to like strangers and
see who am i and that's who you are
whereas like steve north was like you
know these qualities of you then go
opposite whatever these qualities that
you have you're angry or you know
whatever then you go opposite so they
have like different takes which is find
your path take the advice but also find
your path
but you know if if you're looking for
that persona the big thing persona
though
don't rush it
if you're in your first year
don't worry about that learn to write a
joke
you should do that in your first 10
years learn to write a joke
which is interesting because a couple of
them especially stephen rosenfield said
don't be afraid of the diversity of your
joke like if you're just standing there
doing one-liners in your first year but
you've not explored storytelling or
anything else
don't worry about the persona go explore
this stuff you might find what you like
you know and which is something i really
did take away because i tried the one
liners and other things i me
i fit like so easily in storytelling
that i'm comfortable with it and
i try to write one liners and then stick
them in there um
by going that whole one-liner thing i've
tried it and i know i know that's not my
thing but i could say i tried you know i
was i was diverse in defining who i am
yeah it's i i and i
i started with just one-liners and i
think that's tough now with there's more
comedy information than ever you know
and we're big we're probably
i will say a big part we're probably the
part and reason why that is um
you know whether through our content or
what we're doing has inspired other
people to you know steal the idea uh is
really
no it's it's all love but
what what it really comes down to it it
all takes time you know what i mean i
think that's a big takeaway from this as
well is it's like we hear all this
information we're like oh i just
unlocked the secret to comedy but it's
like you literally have to now
go apply each of these things like
incrementally and refine them and make
them your own you know it's not like you
hear this and now all of a sudden you
figured out comedy it's like now you
have to do it you know yeah
it's which is the big commonality too
it's you know
the thing that we preach a lot with hot
breath is do the work write perform
repeat kind of like kind of like washing
your hair red you know wash rinse repeat
comments the same way right before
repeating
when you said wash i just saw yoshi's
face be like what
two of us wash our hair because two of
us have
um
right perform repeat don't you know once
you start to get that and then you start
um developing like you're getting funny
or you're getting those reps says joel
save those rips
then you'll start to find that persona
piece yeah first it's that that big
commonality that everybody's discussed
it's
right right
you know i like what scott dicker said
it was
um you know those days you don't feel
like writing right anyways yes but you
know his words were what are you too
good for this are you and that was my
question i asked him like what what do
what do i do if i don't feel like
writing and he's like oh
you don't feel like writing
you're gonna be like
literally
by the way speaking of scott dicker's
big takeaway
don't be a nazi
there was a big moment there where yeah
there was a big lesson don't be a nazi
and i was he was like i was afraid he
was talking to me from how i look
now people that are watching that did
not that did not listen to that wonder
they're going don't be a nazi what was
that about now you have to go back and
listen gotta go back and listen to it
i'm not going to tell you at which point
he says it but there's a discussion
about don't be a nazi and actually it's
don't be an effing nazi yeah he put it
out there like you know he and he may or
may not be joining me on my q a tomorrow
at 5 00 pm eastern time so just set your
alarms
you know actually he was this he was the
other person said he wanted to come back
and uh do some things oh yeah he'll be
back tomorrow
on my q a that i do at 5pm on this
youtube channel
right on this is that
noise i mean
i mean 20 000 subscribers you know what
i'm saying
we out here
yeah yeah there's a lot of good stuff
yeah yeah
really what um
did you have any others i had i have a
few um
from um the hot breath verse you guys
want to hear some of their takeaways
this one comes from across the pond
from mr harry pike
he had a goodie oh wait
why am i on why am i in the background
why is that the case wait what's
happening
wait a minute
why am i here
wait a minute i see harry pike but i
also see you so maybe if i do
this
there we go
it's good enough
for this free show
all right
i'm just kidding i love you all here's
what harry had to say from across the
pond
yes joel it's your friend harry all the
way from wales uh i absolutely loved the
scott dickers episode in the author
series
it really made me consider all the
different ways that you can diversify
comedy the different avenues you can
take through writing through performing
and the other point that he made that i
absolutely loved is don't try and
recreate something that's already been
done create something new create
something fresh
excellent advice
loved it
yeah so yeah that was a big one yeah
if i if i remember correctly that came
when
um bob was
uh
he was kind of nerding out because he he
looks at scott dickers as a god
and he wanted to know how he could
become a um
a writer at the onion and scott said why
do you want to become a writer at the
end why don't you just go do your thing
which was like
i mean that was a mesmerizing statement
but if i remember correctly that's when
that one came about
which is true because you can't be as
comics
joel cannot be the next steve martin
joel can only be the next joel
yoshi cannot be the next dave chappelle
because i don't know if yoshi can handle
getting beat up or not um
which is funny by the way
by the way scott dickers i actually put
it i actually kind of typed it into the
to the youtube spot but uh one of his
one of the things that actually scott
digger said was
comedy because it was about cancer
culture i asked him about cancer culture
comedy has to have teeth if you're not
offending anyone you're not doing it
right
oh yeah for sure there's got to be
you've got to punch down to somebody but
there's just got to be a universal
sort of rule that whoever you're
punching down to you're allowed to punch
down to you mean like and that's the key
with comedy is somebody's going to be
the brunt of your joke and usually what
helps is if you're the brunt of the joke
right we talk about this all the time on
the joke feedback is like if you talk
about your wife don't make her be the
bad guy make you the bad guy for
recognizing something that you don't
realize and that's a better way of
taking the joke rather than making her
the bad guy because no one knows her
because no one sees her they are seeing
you so i think that that's a good point
it's just
you you have to have
a target to some degree
but i think you know
i even the thought of like
we're all getting canceled just feels
lazy it's like
and
so
whatever just do comedy we've always
been getting canceled you know people
have lost jobs before that's always
happened i think we're just in the world
now where it's just so much easier to
see
people not getting opportunity or
being denied opportunity when that has
always happened
we just didn't see it
and the good thing about where we're at
now in comedy and that's why
i talk about it so much
on hot breath is like creating your own
success creating your own opportunities
a prime example
scott dicker's
telling someone you don't want to work
for the onion you want to create your
own version of the onion or create your
own thing
you know it's like we all have the tools
to do that it's just who's willing to
put in the work to actually make it
happen is is the differentiator now it's
who's willing to put in the work
facts
thanks
let's do a few i got two more for y'all
from uh the hot breath the verse the
next one here is from denise
all the way out in sha town
let's see what denise has to say about
the author series
hello hot breath of earth this is denise
medina in chicago and my takeaway from
the comedy author series was listening
to steve north talk about finding your
persona
the way he broke down flaw blind spot
attitude and agenda and gave real life
comparisons such as rodney dangerfield
and anthony jeselnik i had never heard
those terms before or not quite the way
that they were described and so it
started to make a little more sense for
me because that's something i struggle
with is finding my persona so hopefully
this is going to be a big help to me and
um i really appreciate it uh brother
verse thank you so much joel
hot bread the verse i love it
i love it
persona
yeah the the steve north um and the
reason i ended up contacting him is
because i actually took his one day
class
and it was so in-depth
that
when we when we uh started doing this i
knew i had to give because he had the
book on it you know he's he teaches
these things
to my knowledge he still teaches classes
now so denise
i would say sign up for one of his
classes and take it it's actually it's
absolutely amazing because
he will
take time with you um
to develop help you with your character
and if it's not working after a while
and you email him
he'll have no problem trying to help you
out like he he steve is a really really
good guy really nice guy
um
i've had several conversations with them
he's
he's just fantastic to work with
yeah and even in the interview he was
very thorough in answering questions and
like making sure people understood the
process
but it's it's i think this is a good
time to also bring up like denise said
i'd never heard these terms before and
like she's like i i think they'll really
help out and now it's like okay now it's
time to
apply those incrementally and see what
sticks and what works for you and what
doesn't work for you and really make
that feedback and those insights your
own and apply them to your own comedy
and what comes natural to you and your
sense of humor because he does share a
lot of information and structure in that
interview
but it's like kind of digesting it one
bite at a time and applying it one kind
of technique at a time to really
frankenstein your way into your persona
because it takes time
right yeah it does it does take time you
know this isn't one of those
when you when you build a character with
with steve if it's not working after
like the third time that doesn't mean
quit like it takes time to get used to
what you're trying to do you know like
you know wrestling god bless him rest in
peace gilbert godfrey that wasn't him
that was his character
that loud obnoxious
god that was a character if you actually
like listen to uh actually he had a
documentary on hulu
several years ago and when you hear him
just talk
like person to person
he's a totally different totally
different person
um
and even the way he talked was different
so don't i say that to go back to
when you put that character together um
don't
quit
just because it's not working after
three times it will take time it'll take
time to get comfortable in it um
and to really get it over you know some
of us
don't have the the
the natural thing like you know like jim
brewer jim brewer naturally looks like a
stoned idiot
there's his character you know so he had
it naturally um whereas other people
it's gonna take you a while so
yeah
i mean i didn't even start thinking
about it
and i mean until very recently like
yoshi said at the beginning of this is
like you know
get funny for 10 years and then figure
out your persona you know i mean
i didn't even think about
my persona until very recently or how
i'm coming off to the audience but i
think it does help you find writing
direction
when you are more self-aware of
how you're appearing to the audience how
you're coming off to the audience you
know because now i can make youth pastor
jokes and
things like that knowing how i'm coming
off to the audience but i didn't even
consider it for a while it was just all
writing and performing
so it's it's all a process though so
just give yourselves a break
and just kind of build it on stage one
set at a time and it just it just takes
time i mean yeah i also think like
don't pursue trying to find your persona
i know that's a hard take
but your persona will find you
i really think that i really think like
i think you know after you're doing
comedy for such a long time and you're
on a lot of stages guess what people are
gonna come up to you and be like yo that
joke about like you know i think
we mentioned it we were on a show
together
and you mentioned something about the
hoa joke sort of opened up the room yeah
that's i knew that based on
having worked hoa rooms and working
rooms that like
where that resonated with the crowd but
that's because someone came up to me
after the show and was like yo
that hoa joke that really hit me and i'm
thinking to myself yeah it hits me too
let me expand on this hoa stuff right
and so and i think that's part of like
the feedback like don't forget like your
audience is always also going to give
you feedback on what they're hearing
from you um as well not just random
people i think random not random people
but like your comedy friends and your
you know people who you know will tell
you
but you know my kids don't know i'm like
big into hoa in my comedy but when i'm
doing the jokes at about the hoa at
certain suburban shows they're like oh
yeah i get it because i hate my hoa too
and so i think
just working your own material but
finding
you'll find your voice through your
material so i think it's important just
work your material and the audience will
help you find your persona
yeah they're a key ingredient in finding
it
and definitely don't put yourself on any
kind of timeline to find it you know
just because we're saying five years or
ten years uh it took louis black longer
than that he finally came across it
after i don't know how many years i know
it was longer than 10.
um i remember the story
he came across that by accident in
chicago and finally figured it out
george carlin if you look at this the
career of george carl and his his
character his persona changed he had
three different the beginning he was one
in the set in the middle part of his
career he was the hippie and then he was
the angry old man like it changed but i
will say the best one of the best
stories i've heard
about coming your crush your character
was larry the cable guy you know larry
the cable guy is a complete
character on stage if you hear him off
stage
he's actually
pretty smart he doesn't sound like he
does on stage but he came across it by
accident um i heard him tell the story
you know he just got on stage one day
and
just to do this one bit of
you know i look like the kind of guy
that would come here to like your house
and be like hey anybody order cable
and it was jim brewer and a couple other
snl guys that told him that's a
character that's an snl character that's
a total skit that should be on tv
later the cable guy is born
yeah andrew dice clay was a small
character in his set
that he then made this entire persona
that was then selling out madison square
garden you know and it came through yeah
the audience really resonating with
something
about him and just building on that um
so what
character became
a character by like just a couple of
jokes in the middle of her career and
then it shot off into
that's who she was she was at trailer
track or trailer park wife
stay-at-home wife and then she becomes
this you know big star on tv
but if it was an accident it just it
came to her so don't definitely don't
rush it you know if there's stuff you
want to play with fine but don't don't
rush it don't push it don't
um
let it happen
a few of the authors said it can help to
ask people what they think of when they
see you you know that can be a good
starting point but a lot of it is like
yeah doing material on stage what is
working
and then start to build it that way but
frank said that's a refreshing tip
because he's been doing comedy one and a
half years and is feeling frustrated
because he can't find his
persona yeah it's definitely don't look
for it yet don't look for you yeah
explore your jokes explore i would
suggest
not to like just say just one particular
person author go watch all of our
authors
and then get their book but i have to
say
if there was any two books i can
recommend to a person
kit jerry's book because he covers it
all and steven he covers it all he'll
cover he'll cover your your career from
beginning to your to your pay-per-view
spot or your hbo special to your
downfall and then you rise back up
he covers the whole spectrum it's like
great i'm doing an open mic great i have
an hbo special great i'm broke and i got
to figure out how to do this again and
now you're back on the rise
but like both of them they're
the biggest thing they both were is just
learn the comedy learn the game learn
how to write and write better and write
better and then put in the work
every year and a half i'm only in year
four
i still don't know it
like
i just i'm still working on this i don't
think i know it and i've been doing it
12 years like i don't i don't think i'm
like oh i know what my persona is and
how i can filter my material through it
and all that i mean honest and not but
honestly i don't
give it that much
power i guess or that much emphasis like
i'm not actively studying it either i'm
literally just like reacting to what the
audience is reacting to
and just building material around that
and i think your persona will
organically form
through that it's good to have this
awareness of these professional
instructors
telling you these techniques you can do
to help you get there but it still
requires you to like get on stage
figuring out how to be funny first how
to write a joke
how to stand on stage confidently
because you don't
it's like if you're worried about your
persona then you're up on stage like
okay what is my next joke okay they
didn't laugh at that one what next oh
what is my persona and like
it it's almost like overwhelming so it's
great too much where it's great to be
aware of persona yes but not to hang all
of your comedy validation
on
like all right
what is my personal cool i killed but i
don't really know my persona i'm 12
years in i don't i don't know i always
say you've got your persona
off the stage
that's when you're evaluating how you
came off what happened all those things
on stage you got to work on the jokes
man yeah it's like the jokes and the
delivery of the performance like that's
the stuff that you work on and then you
evaluate off stage and then you're like
okay how can i bring my persona into my
next set all these things but on stage
the jokes
that that's number one get them jokes
get those things out get like be funny
yeah and i think that's the key there um
and then yeah of course work on your
persona but like yeah don't worry about
it like that
it's interesting because even steve
north
did say look
you don't even have to really have it
the persona kind of helps build your
person
but
you can be a joke teller and a comedian
you just
have to have the persona you can make it
work and there's plenty of plenty of
people out there who you can look and
see okay
they're not really a persona or or a
character but there are those
that are so
many comedians
right irreverent
right like how many irreverent comedians
are there or how many comedians are
doing a bunch of comparison stuff what
do you mean that's just what does
irreverent mean a reference
it's just like style right just a style
of comedy and so i think to your point
the persona that we are so attached to
it's more just for us so we can feel
good about it
at the end of the day it's like oh okay
i just want to feel good about what i'm
writing and all this other stuff the
reality is what people laugh at and what
you think is funny that is your persona
at the end of the day
i mean i i would honestly say i don't
think john mulaney has a character i
don't think he's i don't think he has a
character or persona he's just a damn
good storyteller
like he is a great fantastic storyteller
who is selling out right now and making
money because he's perfected
that art of
i can build a story
put in all the techniques put in voices
put in comparisons you know
put all that in and he's selling and
he's making
so if you find it you find it
but the biggest thing is are you making
people laugh
and if you're doing that
let the others let the others come when
it comes if it doesn't come so be it the
biggest purpose is is you're making
people laughing you're getting booked
yeah i agree so yeah and let's um let's
get to uh some joke feedback as well my
friends so do um do post your jokes here
in the live chat and i do want to play
one more clip because it is topical
from uh the hot breath of earth who
talks about persona and kind of his
struggle with it i think it'll i think
it'll help resonate with a lot of people
here from mr
alan
michael harbor hello hot breath of earth
that is denison's voice here's alan's
my name is alan michael harbor and i'm a
comedian in northern florida my biggest
takeaway from this series of authors in
the hot breath podcast is the notion of
comedic persona
anyone who's done the most elementary
research into how to be a comedian has
heard this phrase and from a lot of the
advice i've read it's usually listed as
one of the most important things that
you need to figure out right now if you
ever want to
make it in the
the
business
and that gives me a lot of anxiety
because i mostly do one-liner jokes
right now and i look at comedians like
anthony jeselnik dimitri martin jimmy
carr stephen wright gary delaney etc etc
and they all have defined personas as
one leader one-liner comedians
and it makes me feel like i have to
choose what i'm gonna be right now
but through this series i've learned
different schools of thought when it
comes to comedic persona
and one that resonated mostly with me
was stephen rosenfield
whose basic idea is that you tell
whatever jokes you want from the very
beginning of your career
and as you go you chip away add or
change what jokes you tell and how you
tell them by listening to the audience's
reaction
it's a slow burn but it helps you figure
it out
a few of the other authors like steve
north had similar ways but they
explained it in ways that just
didn't resonate as well with me they
made it seem more immediate so that you
know gave me anxiety
as well like just another way of saying
you have to figure it out right now
but i like the slow burn
so in the end i guess the biggest
takeaway was that i have to keep being
reminded of and will probably be
reminded of again in the future
is that there's no single way to do
comedy you have to find your own path
but again it helps to know how other
people do it
mic drop mic drop alan michael carter
just nailed it right there
there you go kids
look and to add to that with that whole
thing is
enough to keep going back to the persona
thing but think about who you are in
real life and that could really help you
out
like
do you know even what sam sam kennedy
was before he was sam kennison
he was a pastor he was a pastor so if
you take all those those like baptist
pastor
qualities
and think about that that screaming the
screaming that emphasis and hitting it
home
all he did was apply it to his comedy
you know
if it go back and go on netflix and
watch
um john lenkozamo's latin history from
morons
and he takes on the persona of a history
teacher like a high school history
teacher
and because it's a one-man show it's
comedy it's the history of latin america
and
it is absolutely brilliant and he
dresses the part of a teacher he acts
like a teacher he actually there's a few
parts he says hey you got that wrong
that's a debarant i need you to pay
attention because this is going to be on
the test like he puts on that persona
because that was the special
so
you know don't worry my advice again
don't worry about it be right now be
you
just be you
write perform repeat
and if it comes it comes if doesn't does
it the biggest thing
make them laugh
i think mr harbor
said it best and like echoed a lot of
people's concerns probably from this
author series like oh my gosh there's so
much information now i'm worried should
i even do comedy and then i think i
think he nailed it and just saying like
just one shot a time one joke at a time
just build it incrementally like there's
all these techniques and theories
and classes and workshops and books
but
you're gonna learn what works for you by
getting on stage at the end of the day
you know you just you can't out
smart the work you've still got to get
on stage and develop one show at a time
and that's the big takeaway for me
with all this information you have
access to
don't forget
it's one show at a time it's one joke at
a time give yourself a break you're
getting to pursue comedy which most
people are too afraid to do
so just enjoy the process yeah i mean
and as you're listening to
everything my biggest advice is
that you really can't sit and listen to
these podcasts episodes just one time
because it has been one year
joel since we did this and
you know over the last week i had i'd go
back and listen to him because
when you text me about it like hey we're
gonna do this episode
what do you remember i was like wait a
minute
because it was it had been a long second
half of the year so i'd go back and
listen i was like
wait a minute he said this i i'm having
to go back i've listened to them all i
actually need to go back again and just
take notes go through and go through
them slowly
but because there are a few like like
jerry
judy scott and steven
those four
are packed with so they pack 10 pounds
of sugar in a five pound bag sugar okay
sorry
look actually that saying is a little
bit more vulgar but i went with sugar
because it was easier
they packed so much into these episodes
that
into my mouth you mean
kind of like that right there um
but it's packed with so much information
that this is not a sit and get
college class
and their books are the same way you
have to
take your time reading through all of
them and if you get the even if you do
the audible books because a lot of them
are on audible
it's not a sit and get you're gonna have
to back up and do it again and listen to
it again or read it again because
it's that pack i can tell you i've read
jerry's book three times
and i still to because i did take a few
months off
because i was just way too much and i
was burned out
like i'm actually going back home and re
start reading again because there's just
too much the you know you and i
interviewed him twice yeah
within like probably a six seven month
span
and
i'm finding myself i have to go back and
listen to those things over and over
because
jerry is just
a lot of information
yeah but you can't be intimidated by it
and you have to realize like
going back to steven's book stephen's
book will give you the beginning of your
career the middle your downfall your
rise back to fame
which is perfect
don't take this as a sit and get and get
intimidated
because it's impactful take your time
listening through it you're gonna write
people hearing this how can they reach
out to you bo what's the best way to
contact you if they hear this and are
like man beau did a good job on these
interviews i want to connect with him
because he he sips his coffee at 6 00 pm
um smoke smoke signals work pretty good
um you're in our facebook groups i mean
yeah i am in the facebook group i'm on
the you know i'm in the pro page i'm in
the the writing group
so you can find me message me on on you
know private messaging me or whatever um
like me follow me um just don't stalk me
on facebook so facebook's the best
facebook facebook um
i do do a lot of conversating through
instagram
i don't do twitter as much what's your
instagram it's on all
it's a guantanamo
guantanamo
ball
that's that's the name of my special
guantanamo
b johnson comedy on instagram
everything's the same
instagram twitter facebook venmo if you
want to send me some money
um
if you want to send them a haircut
because now
now i gotta get a beard trim um
actually i need a haircut because i want
to look like yoshi no
nice that's going to be kind of hard
though uh
you know
you know hey you might want to send me
money because i think i i think i need
to start working on season two this
summer yeah we're gonna cook up another
one of these for sure but i appreciate
your help with this bow and we're gonna
we're gonna jump in and do some jokes
one last thing something that stephen
rosenfeld said
if you bomb
don't worry about it because probably
the chemistry if your chemistry is not
working with the audience
like there's places in towns that i
don't do well in but i do well in others
and it's the same material
either you are off that night or just
the chemistry don't kill yourself and
definitely don't blame the audience it's
just something between the two of you
it's it's like it's like a really a
girlfriend you know whatever
relationship sometimes that chemistry is
not there and you gotta part ways don't
get intimidated don't don't beat
yourself up
just keep going to the next show write
perform repeat video record
everything
uh dab it out
dab it out well dab us out there bo
thank you so much my friend yeah
thanks for doing this beau thank you for
your help making this happen
[Music]
thank you more than anything joel
because you gave me the platform i never
would have thought of doing a podcast
you know i did a few of the interviews
with you angela johnson um and then i
started doing my own a few of them and
you're like this is you gave me the
platform
and now you let me do this and so of
course it's been fantastic
more to come bo johnson more to come my
friend oh yeah
thank you so much bo
and uh
keep up the great work
thanks
in the past
oh that was awesome dude i love that i
love that
there's one gm here's another gm here's
another gm
so many i think it is a book dude i
think i think we should
i think i think we could make this
series a book you know
oh and jacob said bye bo oh that's so
nice jacob's been watching since the
beginning thanks buddy
yeah man so we do see some people
putting some joke feedback i mean some
jokes for feedback and we we only have a
few minutes here so we're gonna we're
gonna run through them i think we tested
before yoshi didn't we say
this time maybe we're gonna try to do
like a countdown timer
yeah yeah yeah maybe because you know
you and i can go and now we learn that
bo as well we can all just go
you know what i mean let's go
so um
maybe like maybe let's test this time
like a minute each maybe and just see
what we can kind of get done you need in
a minute per joke what do you think yeah
let's try it
hilarious
beau said by the way i just looked and
greg is still talking
takes one to no one i guess hilarious
no i'm just kidding
that's hilarious
so let's um let's get into some jokes
here so the first one
i think i saw tavis post one
um
but it was flagged so i don't think it
appeared oh okay here it is on youtube
all right my co-worker lost his
s
lost his cool
uh on mother's day he kept seeing all
these bump pictures on instagram where
all these moms post pictures of their
baby bumps to remind us that
he's a deadbeat dad
so that feels more factual than jokey
and i think what i'm wondering
what's the beginning of the joke again
my what uh my co-worker lost his cool on
mother's day he kept seeing all these
bump pictures on instagram where all
these moms post pictures of their baby
bumps to remind us that pause he's a
deadbeat dad
so i think the joke is that he's seeing
his baby mamas on instagram posting
these baby bump pictures i just think
it's maybe too wordy
yeah yeah it's got too much too much
fluff the misdirect isn't very clear so
we really need to just like
co-worker lost his cool on mother's day
seeing all these baby bump pictures on
instagram
they reminded him
he's a deadbeat dad
yes
yep
cool that's it yo
the minute timer i don't hate it
i don't hate it
let's uh let's keep it moving to the
next one here
who are you seeing there buddy oh wait
uncle they didn't put joke in front of
it though but it looks like it's a joke
um
i don't know if you can see it you can
read it i'm trying to
yeah one thing me and deodorant have in
common is you will never find us in the
pits at a music fest
i like that
oh i see you posted a lot of jokes
uh
one thing me and deodorant have in
common is you will never find us in the
pits
at a music fest
i think um
i just feel like pits is the punch word
so i feel like it needs to end with pits
you know what i mean
you'll never find us at a music fest
pit
you think that'll hit
or like a music or a concert pit a
concert orchestra pit
mosh pit
um i think it just needs to end with pit
no that's a good point yeah no i like
that
and i think yeah i think instead of one
thing it could just be
i'm similar to deodorant and that you'll
never
find me
in
at or i'm similar to deodorant a concert
you'll never find me in the pit
yeah
i like that i like that yeah i think
that's cleaner yeah um and i think you
could probably do like a power of threes
you'll never pop find me in the pits
the uh
i'm trying to think something else like
the arm or
or something something pits you know
what i mean yeah it just needs to end
with pet
yeah but it just does need to end with
pit
nice all right go via comedy here
what do you call a rastafarian with
glasses
ross to four eyes
[Laughter]
well we don't need to start the timer on
that one i think we got all we needed
from that one thank you for the clever
word play there
um
[Music]
uh where to go oh
john
john mondragon uh i think denny's
calls it the grand slam because right
after you eat it you and your three
friends will have to run home
pretty solid i think it's there
that's there that's definitely there
yeah
i don't i don't hate that yeah
nice job john i mean it's
it's a silly joke like you know i don't
i don't it's i don't
i feel like anyone could say this and
it's still work you know what i mean
it's kind of like something you could
see on reddit and be like oh that's
funny not saying
you like remotely like stole a joke
whatever john it's just it feels a
little more generic so there's a way to
personalize it
to where like even if it's you ate at
denny's and learned
that this example you know that i had to
run home just purslanes a little bit
will make it a slightly less generic and
more uniquely yours
yes that's a good point yeah but i like
it yeah that's funny very funny uh frank
i'm always procrastinating which has
kept me alive since i'm a bit suicidal
wait i did not mean to do the honky
sound
um
just kept me alone
you know i'm
i think there's a way to rearrange this
is
uh
i'm alive because i'm a procrastinator
since i've also thought about suicide or
something of that nature like
there's an element it's you're alive
because of the procrastination
yeah i think the procrastination is the
punch line right
is it like something setting up that he
is suicidal but the procrastination is
what is the misdirection i think that's
that i think that might work i think
even if you just switch the bit right
like i have felt suicidals but luckily
i'm a procrastinator i'm more of a
procrastinator than a depressed or my
depression doesn't beat my um
procrastination or something like that i
think procrastinating being at the end
is the misdirect there for sure
i like this timer
yeah
it really it really gets us gets us to
it you know what i mean
sure
um
is that all of them
that was all of them
foreign hilarious
uh multiple times a bunch of jokes
though
yeah bumble bumble did do a bunch of
them but we only read one just for the
sake of time and um getting to
everyone's jokes and um
i know we usually we went a little over
today but we went deep on the comedy
author series so if y'all haven't heard
those just go listen to our podcast
where we have interviews with all the
top
rated comedy authors in the world
only on hot breath
what i'm gonna say so
we appreciate y'all so much for hanging
out
thank you all for helping us hit 20 000
subscribers as well tell your friends we
out shia
tell your comedy friends how to open
mics and in your own facebook groups and
stuff
we do have a facebook group bumbleton
um
just search hot breath
on facebook and i'll actually paste a
link to it
as we're heading out here
and um
i forgot my announcement
what's that
i'm headlining dallas comedy theater at
the end of the month
dallas comedy theater
yeah the dallas comedy club sorry dallas
comedy club uh
i'm headlining uh the 28th on a saturday
and sunday for memorial day weekend what
yeah yeah yay uh they're still working
on the ticket so if you're out in the
dfw area come see me i've got some
friends coming out but i'm headlining
the show it'll be saturday in the
evening i want to see it's like at 10 30
and then sunday at 6.
yeah man in dallas fort worth uh
dfw area in dallas and deep bellow it's
a great new comedy club they're super
supportive just good people um i want to
say they're probably young to the comedy
club game i want to say maybe like less
than two years but yeah man i'm super
excited so if you're in the dfw area
come see me
and come watch me work these jokes man
i'm so excited 28th and 29th you said
28th and 29th wow that's so cool
congrats fam
dude i'm super excited oh my gosh that's
huge dude i'm so excited for you well
deserved
and i'm like i'm from the dallas fort
worth area so like i i'll have like
people friends and so it's been a while
since people have seen me like you know
i mean like you know your family is like
ah yeah whatever you're doing that art
thing yeah whatever yeah yeah
but just to be like yeah i do this okay
jacob said making moves damn yoshi carol
said yay yoshi
yeah man yo the hot breath versus ouch
frank said way to go
503 dude said totally awesome yoshi this
is sick
yeah man so i'm super excited uh yeah
come holla at your boy if you're in the
area in memorial day weekend absolutely
well goodness gracious thank you so much
for hanging out steve i saw you posted a
joke i'll share some feedback with you
after but i know we gotta we gotta
skedaddle but we love you all so much
uh congrats yoshi that's so cool man
and i'll be back tomorrow at 5 p.m with
a q and a with scott dickers live on
this youtube channel so set your alarm
nice
onion man himself
so funny so pull up on your boy i'll be
back tomorrow at 10 a.m on here as well
doing the right tin club but until then
we love you all so much
we'll see you tomorrow morning
bye y'all
i don't know where the outro
[Music]